hey this way neural Copsey New York
hunting for those two prison escapees
have to admit that this is pretty much
how they'd spend their weekend if nobody
had escaped from prison you gear up and
you go four-wheeling then maybe some
duck hunting you take the boat out and
next it'll be like hey Jimmy you know
what we forgot to look the titty bar
near old Jessica Chastain and Bryce
Dallas Howard must star in a movie that
answers a question I've had for a long
time what happened to those two little
girls in the shining numeral current
events buffs reading about how the avian
flu has caused an egg shortage in Texas
have to admit at least part of the
reason you clicked on the story with
because this photo made you vaguely
horny
I said vaguely new rule stop
interpreting this viral photo of the
raccoon hitching a ride on an alligator
as an example of animal kingdom
friendship as much as you'd like to
think it's some sort of marshland uber
driver it's actually just a gator taking
his lunch to work
new rule as soon as she's feeling up to
it rachel dolezal must go on a date with
Caitlyn Jenner and they both must wear
this dress do you see a black woman in a
gold and white dress or do you see a
white man in a black and blue dress
it's the perfect modern Mindbender and
you know what stop attacking Rachel for
wanting to be black sometimes we white
people can pull it off and sometimes we
can
oh okay sorry one more thing
now that Rachel Dolezal claims there is
no biological proof that she is the
daughter of her white parents Donald
Trump must insist that she produced her
birth certificate and Don speaking of
producing your birth certificate I know
things got kind of crazy when you filed
that lawsuit against me but we never
really did clear up that issue of who
your biological parents
you